a galaxy far far away almost had a stand
in our actual galaxy in 2016 when he was
still attached to direct Star Wars
Episode nine the rise Skywalker
Colin Trevorrow told a crowd at the
Sundance Film Festival that he had
designs on shooting scenes for the flick
in actual space
now before you suggest that Trevor OH
must have been well off his rocker to
suggest such a thing it may be helpful
to know that it's not like no movie
cameras have ever made the journey to
the final frontier most notably the
Warner Brothers documentary Hubble 3d
which followed a group of astronauts on
a delicate mission to repair the Hubble
Space Telescope used IMAX cameras to
film space-based scenes of course these
were shot aboard the space shuttle
Atlantis and not just you know an open
space but the fact remains that movie
cameras did indeed leave our atmosphere
to shoot scenes that we Earthlings would
later watch with our butts planted
firmly in movie theatres seats
apparently hoping to add a degree of
realism to a series in which ancient
orders of mystical space Knights fight
each other with laser swords
Trevor Oh informed the crowd that not
only was he hoping to shoot in space but
that he had actually submitted a request
to the International Space Station to
Hall IMAX cameras on up there and start
filming scenes strangely he had not
heard anything in response the director
admitted I asked the question is it
possible for us to shoot IMAX film
plates in actual space for Star Wars I
haven't gotten an answer yet but they've
shot IMAX in space while that is true we
hear that special-effects houses are
doing really incredible things these
days and that the starry void is fairly
easily rendered on screen with much less
hassle and expense than it would take to
get a film crew on to the ISS for a
month or so one could argue that
Trevorrow had a strangely literal sense
of what it would take to make a Star
Wars movie and that argument would be
bolstered by remarks he went on to make
about his intention to shoot rise of
Skywalker on film rather than digital he
said the only place where I tend to not
be able to attach myself entirely to
something shot digitally is when it's a
period film there's something in my
brain that goes well they didn't have
video cameras then
film tends to remind us of our memories
of our childhoods the way we used to see
films I could never shoot Star Wars on
anything the film because it's a period
film it happened a long time ago okay so
we could spend the rest of the day
poking holes and virtually every word of
that statement but suffice it to say
that eh we don't remember seeing any
film cameras depicted in the Star Wars
movies ever and B if it was absolute
accuracy Trevor Oh was going for he
should have lobbied to shoot the entire
film as a hologram it's a freaking
hologram yes
oddly it would take more than a year and
a half after the Sundance panel for
Trevor oh to be fired from rise of
Skywalker and replaced with Star Wars
Episode 7 the force awakens director JJ
Abrams the usual creative differences
were cited as the reason for his
departure with nary a mention of the
directors the hell with it let's shoot
in space phase fortunately Trevor OH had
another blockbuster franchise to fall
back on Jurassic world the first
installment of which he directed for
sequel Jurassic world fallen Kingdom and
the as-yet untitled upcoming third
installment Trevor OH relinquished the
director's chair in favor of co-writing
the screenplays
we are going to go ahead and guess that
this may be because he wouldn't quit
bitching the idea of shooting certain
scenes in the actual Jurassic period
we're poking a lot of fun here but
Trevor Rose remarks do raise the
question of whether any Hollywood
production has ever managed to shoot
footage in actual space the answer no
but not for lack of trying
in fact Christopher Nolan happened to be
sitting on the same panel when Trevor o
dropped his space bomb and he revealed
that he had actually attempted the same
gambit for his 2014 film interstellar in
the intervening years Nolan has pointed
out that for excellent effort he
selected the same IMAX cameras that NASA
previously used capture real footage
from low-earth orbit but as far as
actual space making an appearance in a
Hollywood film it's never happened and
it almost certainly will not anytime
soon heck all that the last few minutes
of gravity took place in space and if
that utterly mind-blowing flick was able
to portray its setting convincingly
without launching the Sandra Bullock and
George Clooney into the cosmos then it's
a safe bet that future filmmakers can do
the same
no unless and until it becomes cheaper
to deploy space-based film crews than to
simply hire a reputable CGI house we are
not likely to see any Hollywood features
utilizing footage shot beyond the sad
confines of our little planet somehow we
don't think star wars episode 9 the rise
of Skywalker will suffer for the
omission we'll find out when the flick
hits the big screen on December 20th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]